Democrats who were looking forward to
the election of Hillary Clinton and
expecting that it would happen had some
obstacles ahead of them in 2018 for
maintaining majorities in Congress now
with the election of Donald Trump it
looks a little more forbidding for them
the Senate seats that are up in 2018
you've got ten Democratic senators
running for re-election in states that
were carried by Donald Trump that's not
a good place to start off for the
Democratic Party you have very few
Republican seats at risk it's the
opposite of the situation this year and
so the likelihood is that the
Republicans will gain seats
if the Trump administration is seen as
successful when producing good results
Democrats might lose quite a few seats
if the Trump administration is seen as
unsuccessful
Democrats might hold losses down toward
zero so we'll see about that in the
House of Representatives remember Mitt
Romney carried a majority of House seats
226 Donald Trump carried more than that
that's going to make it tough for the
Democrats to gain the seats they need
for a majority in the house
[Music]